let me ask you this
um
you talked about age so let's forget age
Nikki Haley she's running the president
suggested if you're over 75 a cognitive
test
s
you do it again I went to Ronnie Jackson
who was the I mean White House doctor
now Congressman former Admiral I'm
fantastic I should do it again oh I do
it now but I I think I take it a step
further I I don't think it's an age
thing I think a person running for
president you could even say running for
certain offices if you want to know the
truth now I don't know if it's
constitutional because people would say
it's not constitutional but uh I would
say that if you could do it but I'd like
to see it for anybody running for
president I think somebody from running
for president taking a cognitive test
you know they do it in China but it's
done a different way they have a caste
system
and the smartest person gets to the top
I'm glad the smartest person the media
people and people in the Press you've
proven yourself
um at the highest level you can all
right it's some fun questions we're
gonna just change Pace a little bit just
a few of them not many sure
but would Biden should Biden replace
Kamal Harris
he's going to have a hard time doing so
a big percentage of his party is uh
we'll fight him on it it's hard to
believe but they will fight him okay I
think he's going to have a very hard
time doing it what does Donald Trump
miss the most about being president
that I could do so much I'll give you an
example when I said I could fix this war
in Ukraine in 24 hours but you can only
do it from the presidential seat you
can't do it let's say he sent me over as
an emissary you can't do it you have to
be in that position you have to be there
I would set I would fix that within 24
hours and if I win before I get into the
office I will have that War settled 100
sure and everything I said has turned
out to be right you know everything I it
has turned out to be right so you have
the great a great life now you know
besides other than the legal issues
every prosecutor in America you know if
I fly over a Democrat state right you're
the process I jokingly say but if I
fight over I get prosecuted by I have to
go to a grand jury the next morning
putting putting that aside I would say
Donald J Trump has a great life in
Florida in Mar-A-Lago plays golf has
golf courses you play with I know people
that have played with you some of the
most famous and best golfers of all time
have played with you
why why give all that up
to make this next run why because I
think our country is dead we're a
failing nation and I think we're going
to fail completely where a nation in
Decline I say I use the term it's a
horrible term hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else